how many places have you performed out
of curiosity now um
mostly in asia but america australia
singapore malaysia indonesia
germany okay whereabouts in america did
you go san jose california
atlanta georgia anime conventions or
just outside oh okay okay
and uh new york which is my home city so
how was it live performing amazing yeah
yeah
it was amazing um going just going back
there felt like you know
going home so i i felt that uh
like two years ago when i went back
because i'm from sydney
in australia so like uh we have a
convention in australia called smash
yeah like big big anime convention so
like getting invited there as a guest
just felt
so much better than like any other con
experience i've ever been to because it
was
like going back home and being like look
how much this city has grown
it's so amazing because i went to smash
in 2013 when there was like
2 000 people 3 000 people something like
that and the year i went there was i
think
maybe 50 60 000 people that went to the
concert just seeing how much it grew
wow was like you know what i love my
city
this city's
meanwhile i just see a open field and
i'm like wow that's oh that's that's
that's that's awesome that's a lot of
sheep right there
yeah you probably feel amazing though if
you were like invited to a con in wales
though right there's like none there's
like no concept
i i i would like to get invited to a con
in brighton but
like the uk con scene is just
non-existent
really like it's
because we have i think one big
convention which which is not even a
convention it's like
mcm and that's more like an expo and
that's like a comic
gaming films and also anime all right
okay were you a convention girl before
you started actually i've never been to
a convention
really just by myself so that was a huge
big culture like experience for me it's
crazy well
i feel like it's i it would be scary to
go to a convention by yourself
i don't know about your guys's first
convention but uh i mean i didn't go
until i started youtube so
really yeah yeah because i mean well i
mean besides smash in 2013 but i was
already doing youtube back then
right like even then like i had to be
like yo anybody
in my area that knows anything about
anime i don't care if you've only
watched like one episode of dragon ball
z you can just go with me please because
like i don't want to go by myself
because it's f like even at a con with
like a couple thousand people
yeah it's just daunting going on your
own because it's like you get there and
it's like okay there's a bunch of people
who probably like the same stuff as i do
yeah but there's a part of me that feels
really weird just going up being like
so you like anime huh like you can't
really do that
i i totally understand what you mean
because i you i don't know how to
properly break the ice yeah right so it
doesn't help in the uk that no one talks
to each other yeah
when someone talks to you like what the
[ __ ] i feel it'd be so much easier in
america because there's already like
this stranger friendliness
going on right like you can just talk to
someone on the street and they'll
probably reply back to you probably if
you go to an anime convention in america
people will people would approach you
sometimes yeah right if you're just
wearing a cool cosplay or won't work
like that in australia no not in england
at all i've never done cosplay before
have you never
no have you i haven't i haven't well
i've done quite a lot
really he kind of done that for a living
in a sense yeah i've done it like once
or twice i'm
not very cute when i say when they say i
do for a living
that's very sarcastically wow all right
so if you had to start cosplaying who
would be your first cosplay
actually like i i have no idea any
recommendations
you should do a cosplay of like either a
batoon character or like
an rpg like like it would be cool if you
didn't platoon one of the characters
look cool
like safe looking wasn't that one female
character in the tomb
yeah that's that's all i remember was
like it was the blonde hair girl right
yeah in a school uniform yeah yeah well
that's what i'm saying like i feel like
arpeggio would be
a lot more like cosplay friendly because
that's it it's actually like
interestingly looks cool
and like that it would be dope if say
hypothetically
you sang the arpeggio opening in in a
cosplay
of an arpeggio character oh my gosh
that's really like that would be better
that would be meta
that's very cheap it's cheesy but you
know you know
con goals would [ __ ] film over that
well like outside of just like
uh anime that you've sung in like
what are some of your favorite anime
characters that you
would like to cosplay i guess i don't
know but
um like looks aside just just anyone
that you like
ah i don't know i'm putting you on the
spot here i just watched anime now still
lately i haven't been able to watch much
but i've always like in the past one of
my favorite series i've been like
um fullmetal alchemist and my favorite
my favorite
god is no tourist he's notorious for not
having watched it
as he should because it's an amazing
anime it's all right
we're not gonna get into it yeah but i
usually get into enemy through the music
i've always been a musical lover
so um you know any anime with really
good music hooks me on and then i start
watching it but i usually
watch sort of like adventure series
where
the main character is like a guy or a
boy or
not very like muay muy siri right right
right i feel like well like
it makes sense with formal archives
because the bank of the openings in that
are bangers
i haven't seen brotherhood yet but like
the first brotherhood
opening is [ __ ] legendary oh yeah and
also you know the asian kung fu
generation
opening as well like yeah it's so much
so much good music in that
when i listen to anime opening songs i
can't figure out why i like them i just
like the noise
i'm curious if you have like uh like you
must have
like an ear for it right like what makes
a good anime opening in your opinion i'm
curious
if it's sung by me
you can say that as well i'll keep that
as a memo
no um you know i used to listen to anime
openings before i made a debut so what
sort of hooked me on was you know number
one it's
really catchy uh number two um
you know it captures the mood of the
anime
very well um and you know
um i don't know but number i don't what
makes
what makes an anime opening i don't know
because i have no clue i thought maybe
you could
answer their questions i feel though you
kind of answered that like
it is all about like if you just
personally like it it
sticks in your head and if it fits the
theme right
usually though you know um if it's sort
of
what do you call it like jose dickie
sort of you know um individual then
unique
unique yeah um then it sort of stands
out and when something stands out
then like it catches your attention
right yeah because i
remember when i when i was in school and
i watched a load of anime and people
would ask me the question of uh
what what are what are some what are
what are the music you listen to who are
your favorite artists and i go through
like my ipod or something and it's just
all [ __ ] anime openings
and i'm just like oh there's this really
like underground japanese band called
like
asian kung fu generation you probably
haven't heard of them
yeah yeah but that was the thing that i
was like there was some kind of like
level of like superiority in a sense
being like yeah yes i listen to
underground
japanese music you probably never heard
yeah but now
i feel like everyone listens to anime
openings or anime music because everyone
figures out that it slaps hard so now
the superiority is
listening to a band that's done an anime
opening but listening to all the songs
that aren't in the anime exactly
that are like every other song on the
album it's like you only know the
opening i know the rest of the album
no it's it's like i've i've recently
gotten gotten into like a lot of
different artists who like in in like
j-pop and j-rock who
have not been in anime openings or have
not done anime music but
sound like they should have done anime
music and i feel like a lot of those
people
and bands really came up from the
vocaloid community and i don't know
like that's that's why there's so much i
don't know about the vocaloid community
but
everyone seems to have come out of that
community and have this
kind of genre of music that just kind of
appeals to weave i can't
i can't like quantify in words but it's
the kind of music that i just love and i
don't know what that genre is maybe you
tita's
yeah i guess it's like yeah i know i
know what you mean though it's like
it even if the genres are completely
different there's just kind of like a
stylistic or like
something about it where it's like that
sounds like it belongs in an enemy yeah
like you can very
quickly tell like with uh with you know
japanese music if something is like
made for anime and something's not made
for anime there's just some quality
about it that i can't grasp where it's
like
yeah that you can tell the difference in
that right one thing i did realize after
making a w as a sort of anime singer um
was that anime songs and um
well i don't know how do you say the
regular j-pop or j-rock there is a
distinct difference right and um you
know
a lot of people tend to like faster
paced really
like energetic songs and animes because
you're limited to one minute and 30
seconds
and has to catch your attention so um
usually the ballads are
saved for endings and the really fast
pace which is why i started singing like
bpm 200 right like dying
because i've never sung bpm 200 and
after all
after that all my songs became like
really high-paced yeah
yeah i think i tried playing some of
your songs on osu and my mouse couldn't
keep it
so i mean what does that say it's just
like instant copy i'm like
it's going so fast